à
[Musique]
voilà
bravo
[Musique]
je vous explique le programme je me suis
dit que j'allais vous montrer ce qui se
passe est un peu dans la vie d'un
créateur contenu sur trois jours sur une
journée cela me paraissait pas forcément
avec le bon format parce que je passe
autour de soi des facs sont un peu leur
format un peu particulier notamment
aujourd'hui parce qu'on va à lyon on va
découvrir un truc cool ça vous allez
voir ces malades très très marrant donc
je vous emmène sur trois jours pour
partager ma et pays voir ce qui se passe
de prêter une vidéo qui est un peu long
mais ça vachement intéressant
aujourd'hui on va prendre un coucou en
avion on part à lyon on va voir un match
de foot c'est au pot qui nous emmène
c'est un match entre l'ol et l'unicef à
vous expliquer c'est pour une bonne
cause soirée de gala après demain on
revient ici à paris demain soir et à la
google you sell les grandes annonces de
google doit faire une fois par an on ira
chez google france directement pour voir
ça et puis après après demain on va
aller voir d'autres marques on va aller
chez one pluzz qui ont des nouveautés à
nous dire mais il faut pas en parler
après on va aller le soir chez au wawel
après midi on ira faire un podcast chez
sony enfin bref plateau de super cool
tous embarquent c'est des coulisses et
du off on n'a jamais fait ça mais on le
sait est bas mais par contre là on va
commencer à regarder ces voix là il est
7h26 du matin cet art 26 dans moins de
deux heures j'ai un taxi qui m'emmène au
bourget et là tout de suite je le fais
un peu de sport
[Musique]
ça c'est nouveau casque sony j'utilise
il sort demain il est pas encore sorti
mais il faut laisser aux conditions donc
je suis hyper frustrant avec
[Musique]
qu'importe les i plaisir partagé youri
au real majorque mtv ema des formations
rien j'ai eu vent des formations savage
accueilli du mal à des formations
nathan
ça
merci pour le programme merci d'avancé
pour eg alexis margot bonjour ça va ça
va tout va bien mais ça va ça va ils
vont bien regarder aujourd'hui on fait
ça c'est le problème de la journée match
des héros on à lyon alors collation des
parcours le stade bus joueurs unicef vu
des joueurs ol légende aux quais bus
partira diagne aime bien la gnagna il y
aura même une soirée et ça les soirées
on s'y connaît
alors que je vous explique ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui on est au groupama stadium à
lyon et il ya un match qui s'appelle le
match d euros en fait c'est un match qui
est organisée par l'unicef pour
permettre et des à côtés des fonds pour
les enfants en ukraine c'est l'idée
aujourd'hui donc c'est au pot qui est
partenaire et qui m'a invité avec
d'autres créateurs dont conviendra en
tout dit on est là pour parler
l'événement pour permettre de récolter
de récolter un maximum d'argent pour
pouvoir rêver les enfants écrit même que
c'est vachement cool et alors c'est un
max en fait on va retrouver avec d'un
côté une équipe de l'ol avec des joueurs
je dirais une équipe un peu plus
anciennes contre des guests et l'équipe
de l'unicef composé il ya quoi il ya des
morisques ya des musiciens il ya des
influences sourire des sportifs quelle
tony parker après c'est vachement cool
et ça se passe aujourd'hui tout de suite
la renvoyer donc là on arrivait
largement en avance on attend et ça va
être cool donc là il ya l'avant match
est un match on va descendre également
je vais vous montrer en fait on va aller
filmer différents trucs pour relayer
pour permettre effectivement et pas
récupéré de l'oseille parce qu'il faut
voilà donc assez
[Musique]
vous voyez on est juste au bord du
terrain
comme ça va commencer d'ici trois quarts
d'heure alors ça c'est un truc assez
cool avec randolph est fait pour arriver
balader sur un banc de terrain comme
savoyard et charisme nord derrière
pas dégueulasse c'est le bon côté des
choses très honnêtement c'est le très
bon côté des choses et c'est là où on
vient veut savourer truc alors pour
autant c'est une journée de présence et
une journée où il faut être là où
s'écoule spectacle c'est pour la bonne
cause tout ça c'est bien
je regardais franchement la vie ici est
là c'est énorme regardez large pas si
vous reconnaîtrez il ya quand même pas
mal de personnes très très très connu un
de très grands joueurs qui sont juste là
et ces voix là à ces dingos
garder ça c'est le bus ol et ça c'est le
bus unicef alors on connaît le parking
ils sont garés juste là vers la sortie
voilà comme pas sympathique
c'est là j'aime partie du métier c'est à
dire qu'une fois qu'on ne regardait pas
chemin c'est fait c'est ça gallas est
hostile
voilà voilà
donc le match est terminé
[Musique]
et là il nous reste un petit moment
on était un peu
heureusement recommencer tous les
honneurs c'est la première année or
encore 2
il est 7h prendre de fil plus tard hier
soir avec la soirée de l'unicef et de
l'ol c'était cool dans merde je pense
trois quatre heures pas plus vraiment
une gueule ce matin je fais hyper peur
alors vous est ce que le programme donc
là on est à lyon on va reprendre un
avion va remonter à paris ensuite il ya
quoi moi j'ai toujours à compte au fur
et à mesure parce que ce soir ya les
google hayoz c'est une grosse annonce de
google qui vont avoir lieu là donc ce
soir on va les regarder ça ça va être
cool qui vous emmener avec moi pas mal
de choses à faire au studio alors je
suis assez content de la journée d'hier
c'était très très cool honnêtement sur
cet événement maintenant le truc qui
était pas cool c'est qu'en fait j'ai pas
réussi à faire tout ce que je voulais
faire sur mon planning je voulais
tourner une vidéo sur les nouveaux
casques de somme il wmx n 5 et j'ai pas
elle tant dans la journée donc c'était
un peu c'est un peu relou parce que je
voulais vraiment que ça sort ce soir à
la lever l'embargo mais j'ai pas eu le
temps donc je vais essayer d'avancer au
max tout à l'heure en rentrant et puis
voilà d'autres trucs un peu comme ça
mais bon sinon regardez c'est comme ça
je vous emmène et puis j'espère que ça
vous plaît
[Musique]
m
tu camille devant pour avoir la
collation en fait c'est ça s'éteint le
mec il a trop fait oh la la
bg pourquoi il ya que mon cul sur le
poteau
[Musique]
témoin au poker va si on voit pas ou peu
cher
bon fraîchement arrivé de lyon alors
reste les agents blé je regarde mon
emploi du temps j'attendais collige
d'avoir une nouvelle table à qui veut
dire s'installer dans le studio parce
qu'en fait regarder aujourd'hui
tout c'est pas possible en fait
aujourd'hui il ya cette table lala qui
est posée ici dans le studio ça c'est
bien mais c'est pas pratique parce que
c'est une espèce de plateau sur des
tréteaux je veux le bouger et je vais me
remettre une table à hauteur réglable
avec un casque à pour venir à imposer ça
proprement que je pour dépasser sur
roulettes permettra d'avoir un set-up
maître du matos ici mais également
pouvoir la déplacer la m ici sous
l'escalier à si besoin de rsa est
vachement cool donc je devrais recevoir
ça aujourd'hui c'est vrai y avoir
plusieurs cartes ont donc ça ça va être
atelier à réception du matos donc ça ça
devrait me prendre un petit peu de temps
je devrais recevoir un autre colis d'une
autre maquis mike leigh ne sais pas qui
c'est il ya ça un coursier qui devrait
également arriver j'ai un coup de
téléphone à 14 heures pour une marque
produit que vous montrez sur tik tok
c'est la structure à la regarder c'est
ça s'appelle wade bosh est en fait une
brosse à dents qui vous permet de vous
brosser les dents en trois secondes 3 6
2 5 10 et 15 secondes donc ça va
extrêmement vite une en fait c'est de la
vibration sonic et j'ai vu ce serait
donc ça on sent la fin de ce type tout
comme appareil ultérieurement et puis
ensuite on va filer à la google i/o pour
18h30 sans oublier qu'il ya un coût très
important à tourner aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est le nouveau casque de sony donc
j'ai déjà parlé tout à l'heure donc
voilà on s'est mis à regarder ça ça fait
partie du quotidien c'est à dire les
petits paquets qui arrive aujourd'hui on
reçoit un truc que je voulais voir
depuis un petit moment
à savoir
galaxy boucle de pro à 176 grand retour
des ordinateurs de 2,5 secondes en
france et je voulais présenter quand on
était aussi par ce vaisseau va baisser
les ai vus et dont même la gr domaine
leur choix bon sens qu'on regardera
également un peu plus tard bon ça va
être ça aussi c'est cool et ça fait
partie au quotidien de bain de recevoir
des colis de faire partir par coursier
d'un côté de l'autre
bon
[Musique]
newcastle
oh
[Musique]
c'est en tout cas ce intéressant fait
déjà parce qu'on a un vrai changement au
niveau de ce à quoi ressemble ce
smartphone a pas le faire quand j'ai des
trucs comme ça
on
[Musique]
et
lui rue de londres juste derrière moi
c'est l'adresse de google france ô
et si je suis déjà venu mais à chaque
fois je trouve que le lieu est
magnifique
klein on est dans la cour de google
google france regardez ça c'est la cour
je suis en train de tourner donc il ya
eu la conférence de google ayo qui a
duré deux heures on a regardé ça
s'écoute la sécession une interview dont
l'installation du matos discussions on
l'a fait avec jalil pour parler
effectivement de tout ce qui est
software et là on va parler avec
constantin de tous car doivent encadrer
sa sur la vidéo youtube mais voyez
merveille l'art pas mal dans la cour
google france y'a personne il est
presque 22 heures 21h44 est riche et 13
cents par jour vous voyez c'est aussi ça
le les joies du taf pouvoir se retrouver
dans des conditions assez
exceptionnelles dans ce rôle
exceptionnel en ayant accès à plein de
choses et ça c'est auxiliaires ont
laminé
00h37 fin de journée du du mercredi
enfin on est jeudi matin dans la nuit
mercredi à jeudi j'ai eu des petits
soucis sur le tournage que j'ai fait là
problème de son sein le relou donc je
suis en train de tout envoyer pour que
ça parte en montage parce que c'est une
boîte qui me fait mon montage
aujourd'hui quand je fais ça ce que je
fais c'est que j'écris à brive je leur
ai qui touche leur expliquerai ce que
j'ai tourné voilà les différents plans
voilà à quoi ça correspond voilà ce
qu'il faut ce que je veux je vous mets
la musique comme ça ils ont toutes une
feuille de route et ils n'ont plus qu'à
faire comme moi je les imagine dans la
tête qu'ils aillent pas forcément
toujours président voilà un peu le truc
donc là je leur envoie je suis en train
de faire tous les exports et puis il va
être l'heure d'aller se coucher parce
que je me lève dans cette heure pour
commencer cette dernière journée qu'on
va regarder et ça sera encore en rythme
un peu différent j'ai vraiment vous
faire cent soixante douze heures parce
qu'en fait ça montre vraiment plein de
choses différentes que je peux faire
dans monte à ce que ce soit je vous dis
sur un voyage que ce soit là sur un
tournage ce soir et voilà et demain
matin on va faire un deuil avec marc on
va enregistrer un podcast on a un
tournage à faire entre temps et le soir
on a un autre dîner donc ça va être cool
voilà donc à peine chose marrante qui se
passait et puis nous emmener avec moi
fait une aventure ensemble est déjà une
plan c'est parce que je cale bien mort
malheureusement comme trop souvent la
merde ça c'est le repas de ce soir et ça
ça c'est le repas de midi c'était moi
bien là on dire
asiatiques et puis c'est très bon mais
là ce soir je sais juste que chaotique
typiquement là ce soir je me couche je
suis vraiment pas satisfait je suis pas
contente que j'ai fait le tournage de ce
soir était pourtant qu le lieu était
cool j'avais des supers personnes avec
qui parler c'était super mais j'ai eu un
problème de micro qui m'a planté une
interview et je pense qu'elle sera pas
exploitable donc je m'en suis rendu
compte à temps et on a réussi à faire un
backup et faire un truc pour ce soit
cool parce que autant des fois la
qualité vidéo et sur certaines
conditions c'est qu'on peut être un peu
en dessous mais on arrive à récupérer
cessé de la vidéo on récupère toujours
le truc mais il faut un bon audio si
j'ai pas un bon son je peux faire ce que
je veux je peux dans la plus belle image
on va zapper parce que c'est horrible
donc là un choix là c'est super relou
les conditions de lumière n'était pas
super mais bon je pense que en post prod
on peut réussir à faire des choses parce
que tourner en flat donc on peut réussir
à faire des trucs mais mais ce côté là
avec le fouet non voyez là il est 1h du
mat
je suis pas content et voilà fait chier
mais bon c'est comme ça permet main
[Musique]
chaud
moscou
att
opération sport fait on va maintenant
aller se voir une marque on va aller
parler avec une marque mais pas trop
vous dire cela ce passé
[Musique]
en eo hoxton à paris qui est un super
hôtel dans le sentier férus des sentiers
d'ailleurs pas vous montrer parce qu'en
fait une presse qui mêle faits sous
embargo donc quand tu vois des produits
laval on reparlera plus tard mais tout
ceci n'est pas du tout le droit de vous
en parler a eu l'idée là c'est une
petite rencontre un peu entre
journalistes médias ou y rencontrer des
équipes de la marque on va me regarder
un peu ce qui se passe peut-être que je
pourrai montrer de trois têtes mais donc
le gage pas vous montrer le micro n'est
rien que pour ça je suis aussi beaucoup
à paris parce que ne vivent pas tout le
temps à paris c'est le pouvoir
rencontrer des mares discuter avoir des
discussions un peu informel et pouvoir
comprendre deux choses pour un témoin
vous expliquez vous les relayer
directement sur youtube et c'est ça qui
est génial alors lui c'est le mec il se
met toujours devoir tirer un peu le
fayot de service mais on t'aime
tellement
sûre toutefois tutoyer je remercie m
salut l'artiste salué les loulous en
fait en train de faire une vidéo wen 72
heures dans la vie d'un trader ah merde
a toujours expliqué voilà je sois proche
d aujourd hui donc on est sur la fin des
72 heures ce soir ce soir on s'envoie
mais on ne dit pas que toute faute sans
faux pas dire on va dire
voyez il ya du monde donc quand tu
bosses pour qui je bosse pour signer de
france
mais de l'autre côté on va vous montrer
parce que c est sous embargo elle nous a
tendance à le croire nous sommes
julien c'est quand la halle à lever
l'embargo pour parler des producteurs
présenté
neuf saisons on dit pas qui tu es un ça
marche ça vole merci alors comme hier
soir
là normalement c'est un peu plus aussi
regarder ce que je mange normalement
sociale si ça devait pouvoir me
permettre de gagner quelques points de
vie tenir la journée parce que la
journée est loin d'être terminée on a
rendez vous alors à journée parce que là
j'ai un rendez vous à 14 heures mais
c'est pour moi ensuite il faut que je
prépare tout mon matos pour le podcast
parce qu'on est 17h chez sony france on
va enregistrer un podcast qui va durer
20 25 minutes une heure car but on sait
pas ça dépend ça dépend complètement
ensuite jusqu'à 18 heures max 18 heures
je reviens ici je pose mon matos est
arrivé vers 19 heures et ensuite j'ai
rendez vous à 19h30 voilà un peu le
programme donc là il faut que je me
marie puis surtout j'ai une miniature à
faire j'ai toujours pas fait la
miniature de ce cas ce que la vidéo sera
18h ce soir pour la lever l'embargo donc
la fouge me magne un peu de le faire
j'ai une vidéo a tourné aussi là tout à
l'heure à 15 heures jeux parce qu'il ya
vingt ans donc je me dépêchais de manger
parce que sinon je vais jamais y arriver
c'est pas possible d'or bordel comme ça
ici offre alors pas bougé
je suis à la défense le sar ou pas c'est
bien ben bon donc j'ai rendez-vous à 6
minutes soit dix interpellations
d'arrivée ainsi mais je sais pas quand
coupet
[Musique]
et
merci beaucoup c'est très chouette de
faire le podcast ensemble donc voilà
donc normalement samedi elle est en
ligne bonne continuation à bientôt de
faire sa bande bouge chez toi
petit couac avec la vidéo qui devait
sortir la lah et donc hop là elle a été
reposée et donc je fais mais c'est ça la
modifier nos risques tout de suite mis à
côté de toi
salut
les chinois c'est toi qui te retrouver
sur youtube fait gaffe à toi quand même
[Musique]
on termine regardez
c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est organisé par exemple face on
attendait court puisqu'il pour sauver la
sécu
technologie des médias tout le monde est
là on dit plutôt rouge abolhassan
été ça parle pas du tout c'est vraiment
le bon moment
pour
aller parler de mon
inspiration
fait soi est un bon moment
m
[Musique]